listen tell me about your relationship
with Drake Benny oh cool man
drink cool in the studio we'd be late in
the studio about 3:00 4:00 in the
morning you know I'm saying he always
hit me up we need on his creative [ __ ]
and I'm saying it's a regular
relationship and I'm saying he takes I
sex and we keep is there gonna be a
Drake record huh Drake record you want
here you got it
way to play it play there's a Drake
feature yeah yeah is that for your
project is that for Tanner talker is
that for his [ __ ] actually I said him
over so if he used the one I sent him
then you know I'm saying
hopefully yo I think up man I'm excited
it's not another person who didn't have
to reach out to me or mention my name
and I like that you know I'm saying it
and Drake jet on it for the record Drake
is a Jedi that's a compliment
a humble one and here type of person who
done favors for people and you know I
mean people still throwing shade he
talked about it his songs all the time
I'm saying a person who get on people's
songs it's one of the biggest artists
and do people favors and people still
try to slight him and shake him like
that's crazy for him to still be if
doozie ass think about other artists and
still do it you know I mean so shout out
the drink a hundred percent now